tag für tag versammeln sich menschen auf
den straßen russlands sie demonstrieren
gegen den krieg gegen putin
ihr protest kann sie ins gefängnis
bringen kritik am regime putin ist
verboten und trotzdem seit tag eins des
krieges seit letzten donnerstag der
tägliche versuch der freien
meinungsäußerung in der öffentlichkeit
wir schämen uns für dieses land war
an dem ersten protesttag lernen wir die
18-jährige anerkennen das ist ihre erste
demonstration
meine eltern haben mir gesagt gehen
nicht zu dieser demo aber
wissen sie ihr ein krieg das kann man
sich doch nicht ruhig mit ansehen
nach einer stunde wird die demo
aufgelöst und anna wird festgenommen wie
etwa 2800 weitere demonstranten an
diesem tag ihre erste demo ist erst mal
nur eine ordnungswidrigkeit nach einigen
stunden wird sie aus dem polizeirevier
entlassen
drei tage später besuchen wir sie ihre
heimat eine hochhaussiedlung in den
randbezirken moskaus die 18-jährige ist
arbeitslos träumt von einem linguistik
studium im ausland
eigentlich wollte sie mit den eltern aus
wandern in die usa ihre familie hat vor
zwei jahren eine greencard gewonnen doch
dann kam corona nun der krieg
ich liebe mein land die menschen die
kultur aber ich verabscheue die
regierung ich möchte daran glauben dass
es besser wird aber das fällt mir schwer
anna ist aufgewachsen in einer sehr
liberalen familie die eltern
respektieren auch dass sie bisexuell ist
und stehen kritisch zur regierung die
familie hat eine strikte regel niemals
den fernseher anschalten außer es läuft
sport
so gut wie alle tv programme werden von
der regierung kontrolliert
und die verdrehen die nachrichten und
verbreiten propaganda es
was mich so sauer macht ist dass sie
erzählen es gäbe kein krieg nur eine
militär operation aber was soll der
unterschied sein dass die differenz
[Musik]
der widerstand gegen den krieg ist da
zwei frauen sie wollen nicht erkannt
werden sie kleben plakate nein zum krieg
heißt es auf den flugblättern wie
gefährlich dieser protest ist erfahren
wir am eigenen leibe nur wenig später
stoppt der russische geheimdienst unser
auto unterstellt uns wie sein
drahtzieher der aktion das team wird
befragt dann lässt man uns weiter fahren
die repressionen im regime putin nimmt
von tag zu tag zu erst vergangene nacht
wurden zwei der letzten unabhängigen
medien abgeschaltet offizielle
begründung die verbreitung von
falschmeldungen etwa die verwendung der
worte krieg und invasion die staatliche
medienaufsicht bestraft all jene die
putins krieg nicht als spezialoperation
un-friedensmission bezeichnen
verabredung mit der anderen seite mit
denen die putins narrativ unter die
leute bringen was sagt der leiter des
russischen schriftsteller verbandes zum
krieg
für mich als ehemaligen soldaten gibt es
den begriff krieg und den begriff
sonderoperation
ein krieg ist die einnahme eines fremden
gebietes die nutzung ihrer bodenschätze
und die gefangenschaft der bevölkerung
als klar
das ist kein krieg eines der kriterien
ist erfüllt das ist eine sonder
operation
im schriftsteller haus wurde zur ersten
sitzung des sogenannten internationalen
anti nazi kommitees geladen hier treffen
wir den chefredakteur der patriotischen
zeitung nationaler kurs der findet das
sei ein krieg aber
es kämpft nicht russland gegen die
ukraine und nicht einmal russland gegen
das ukrainische narzisstische
marionettenregime sondern es kämpft
russland gegen die usa auf dem
territorium der sowjet
dennis janisch ist mitglied der
nationalen befreiungsbewegung sie
verfolgen putins kurs und wollen den
einfluss der russischen föderation
vergrößern so wie zu sowjetzeiten
dort auf dem gebiet der ukraine ist das
russische volk aber man hat es einer
harten propaganda unterworfen man hat es
verblödet und eingeholt und einen teil
von ihnen verwandelte man den nazis
sobald wir beginnen die städte der
ukraine zu befreien sobald wir die
befreiung vom nazismus beginnen werden
unsere brüder schon einsichtig werden
zurück zu anna sie hält das für plumpe
propaganda die junge frau stellt uns
ihren vater vor der ist
systemadministrator er ist stolz auf den
protest seiner tochter gleichzeitig habe
er angst weil er um die repression weiß
ist sein protest still er geht plakate
kleben dann wenn es keiner mitbekommt
nacht
wenn man jetzt schweigt dann befürwortet
man den krieg das ist eines der
flugblätter das regime putin hat einen
krieg begonnen ein krieg den niemand
braucht weder russland noch die ukraine
seit donnerstag sei russland das
furchtbarste land der welt findet rom an
[Musik]
foto sturm so dass putin ein bösewicht
ist es dort schon lange klar
doch das nun liegt außerhalb von gut und
böse in putin ist der teufel zum
vorschein gekommen und in russland zum
präsidenten geworden
ob er die konsequenzen dieses interviews
früchte wollen wir noch von ihm wissen
jeder der einen funken aufrichtigkeit
besitzt muss sich jetzt gegen diesen
krieg positionieren
roman und anna machen ihren widerstand
öffentlich auch weil sie immer noch ein
bisschen hoffnung haben dass putin
diesen krieg doch noch beendet
[Musik]